we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p here is a voicemail that
came in very very early this morning yes
there's a massive massive undeniable
amount of evidence that germans when
Karen Tina so the question is if it were
could send a bunch of his people to
Argentina safely why would he kill
himself why wouldn't he just go to
Argentina
that makes no freaking sense so this is
someone following up on the Hitler fled
to Argentina hatred mail that we had
yesterday and I think that the caller
believes the conspiracy right that
Hitler did go to Argentina and didn't
kill me I was like in a bunker yeah I
mean okay I think that would be pretty
hard to do especially if you're the most
wanted man in the entire world yeah and
the wars ending and you're wanted you
can't just flee and he also had to stage
his own death with a look-alike right
yeah there's a lot of complexity to that
one I interestingly though at least two
people in our audience believe it we've
got a great bonus show for you today I'm
out of time but trust me it's a really
really good one I encourage you to get
access to the bonus show through either
being a patron or being a member and
we'll speak to you then